welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and let's break down Marvel's Loki
season 1 episode 5 journey into mystery
the void episode journey into mystery
was the title of the original comic room
that introduced Loki and Thor and ahead
of season two we are doing a Loki one
re-watch and we were able to find even
more details in Easter eggs even a new
deleted scene so let's check out this
crazy episode of Loki season 1 with a
fresh set of eyes and talk about how
there might actually be Teletubbies
bopping around the void okay the journey
into mystery Comics were originally a
horror Anthology that then morphed into
big monster stories and this is a most
Ordinary episode of Loki thus far and we
do see a giant monster but first we open
the Chrono monitor screen which This
Time Shows gormir Seoul South Korea
Zimbabwe and Oak Island Nova Scotia
which has been a point of interest for
Treasure hunters for years due to rumors
of famous riches and artifacts being
buried there including Marie
Antoinette's Jules and the Holy Grail
the camera flips upside down and we get
this invert pretty shot of the TBA
signifying how this world has been
turned upside down by the Revelation
that everything about this place is a
lie despite that all the office drones
who we know now are all variants go
about their day to complete their
mundane tasks blissfully unaware the
camera rotates as the back wall
dissolves into the timekeeper elevator
doors which then dissolves into their
chamber right after the battle severed
Android heads still on the floor smoke
billows forth on the ground and the shot
transitions to the Smoky cloudy void
with the camera flying over the ruins of
this place we see a bunch of the
interesting Easter eggs and famous
locations real world history like the
Lighthouse of Alexandria one of the
seven wonders of the ancient world that
became an abandoned ruin after being
damaged in multiple earthquakes there's
also a pruned sanctum sanctorum Tower QE
and G that's the version of Avengers
tower that Mr Griffin one of Kang's
identities bought from Tony Stark in the
comics and we saw I think of Mr Griffin
as a king variant at the end of Ant-Man
that was quantum Mania across from the
tower is a building labeled Ken Park
2018 2018 would be right around the snap
and this might be when Kang Enterprise
has moved into the tower in the 616 MCU
the camera pushes in on Loki and the
variants standing in front of a pruned
bus stop and they waste no time what is
this place where oh who are you is it
the void that's alive and where's his
lunch come on in the comics eliaith was
the first being who broke free from the
constraints of time it's a trans
temporal entity that destroys everything
in its path and causes massive
disturbances across timelines Kang
eventually trapped Elias by creating a
barrier that it couldn't cross but here
in the MCU eliaith acts as a kind of
guard dog for the void director Kate
Herron said eliot's design was inspired
by a few things like thermal lightning
and volcanic eruptions and that she
wanted to tease the full reveal for as
long as possible just like the shark in
Jaws Sylvie finally gets to confront
rensslayer this is it isn't it
this is where you dragged me after you
stole my life the mission she's been on
for countless years to kill all those
responsible for disrupting her happy
childhood and destroying everything
rensslayer talks they'll be out of
killing her by claiming that she wants
answers too we know from a later scene
that rensslayer was a regular teacher or
high school principal on Earth at some
point in time in Fremont Ohio 2018 but
she was very chill when she saw that the
timekeeper was an Android and I think
she knows more than she's letting on in
this moment she explains how the void
works when we prune a branched reality
it's impossible to destroy all its
matter basically the branch timeline
isn't reset it transferred Rensselaer is
appeal to law of conservation of matter
the first law of thermodynamics that
says matter cannot be destroyed only
transferred rensslayer says that the
Dogma states that the timekeepers are
transforming the void into a Utopia when
creating the void Kate Herron said that
she wanted it to be drab and desolate
and upon seeing the constructed set she
joked that she had essentially created
England her home country but she was
also inspired by the Teletubbies stating
quote I wanted the void to feel like a
kind of overgrown Garden because it's
like this forgotten place it's like the
Teletubbies it's like Rolling Hills of
dystopia but it's not sunny it's got
this kind of mist so yeah definitely not
a Utopia we cut back to the void and
more ruins visible a three-masted wooden
ship that appears to be the Mary Celeste
a merchant ship that was found and
abandoned adrift in the Atlantic Ocean
in 1872. to this day no one has any idea
what happened to the crew so maybe
they're all prune variants working for
the TVA now or they were gobbled up by
Elia there's also a huge Flying Saucer
and then what looks like red skulls
spitting rocket from the first Captain
America film which was based on a real
German World War II fighter plane the
Loki's passed by these bird creatures
that are named narvas after Loki's head
of production design Kasra farhani's
daughter narva and Kazar parharni is
actually going to direct a season two
episode we also see several bald head
statues partially buried in the ground
that look kind of like the big head
sculpture in Canmore in Alberta Canada
farhani said quote originally at some
point I was proposing a far more
Salvador dali-esque dada-esque version
of the void and it evolved over time but
those bird creatures and heads made it
through from the dada-esque version to
the English Moors version of the Void
man they're really beating up on England
I think it's a beautiful
Loki argues argues with his variants
Loki Richard Grant dressed in Loki's
1962 Jack Kirby designed attire from the
comics there's boastful Loki whose
clothes look like the dark rain era of
Loki he wields a version mjolnir made
from a piston and a piece of train rail
kid Loki who carries Loki's Leva teen
sword and alligator Loki an original
variant for this series he was designed
by industrial Light and magic and they
used a real-life emotional support
alligator named Wally to get his
movements right he's fully CGI but they
had a stuffed stand-in during filming
and I would just love to see that
footage they walk by a huge pile of TVA
cafeteria lunch trays because why claim
him when he can just print them and then
kid Loki reveals that his Nexus event
was that he killed Thor this explains
why the others treat him with such
respect and the look on our looky's face
after this proves that he's fully one of
the good guys now because he is Shook
and sad There is a giant Yellow Jacket
helmet the suit worn by Darren cross and
Ant-Man before he ended up in the
quantum realm and got turned into Modoc
we also see the Thanos copter from when
Spider-Man bought Thanos in the Spidey
super stories comic from the late 70s
next to it is this big Warhead that
matches the yellow and black on the
copter the production designer said the
bomb was an homage to Dr Strangelove but
with the Japanese atom bomb I love that
being an alternate timeline that like
you know Harry S Truman could have found
a way to prune because he really wanted
to bomb Japan and then yell in
oppenheimer's face the Loki's enter a
hatched in the ground just like the
hatch and lost and the camera travels
downward and a floorboard gag shows a
bunch of stuff buried underneath we see
more lunch trays and Civil War
millionaire and then a jar with t-65 on
the label and trapped inside is frog the
Thor variants that we first saw in Thor
comic issue 365. we recently got a
deleted scene from the season one
physical media release showing this
little guy voice fight Chris Hemsworth
oh damn
turned me into a frog
now this layer here is a 360 degree set
the far honey imagined as a fractured
bowling alley with a slide element to it
all the lines there are visually drawing
your eye to the throne which we imagine
was an old Santa Throne from a mall
pulled from a deleted reality you can
actually see big old candy canes
surrounding it there's also a space
mission pinball game from arcades in the
mid 70s and a polybius arcade box which
is part of an urban legend from the
Portland area in the 80s that claimed
the government rigged up this highly
addictive game for hypnosis and mind
control purposes and then one night men
and black showed up and took all the
machines away rensslayered Miss minutes
meanwhile tried to stall Sylvie by
pretending there is a spacecraft that
can travel into the void find Loki find
the man behind the curtain and kill him
get another in a long line of Wizard of
Oz references we'll meet the wizard in
the final episode Wren Slayer and Miss
minutes have terrible poker Faces by the
way Sylvie sees right through this ruse
and again for the second time in the
series Sylvie steals rensslayer's Tim
pad she knows she has only one move left
and that is to prune herself oh one shot
energy huh I think I'll try it
wow
[Music]
so what is one shot's focused shoe do
I can see it
hey Charlie
[Music]
so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with one shot
energy today by going to one
shotenergy.com new rockstars for 10 off
your order back in the Loki Lair they
listened to Mike Flowers pops cover of
Wonderwall described in the captions as
pleasant music okay it's an
intentionally hokey cover of the Oasis
song they drink Roxy wine exceptional
Pinot Noir box wine from rocks cart
classic Loki pour some box wine down
Loki Gators open maw our Loki has a tiny
chalice compared to the others kid Loki
drinks a Hi-C Ecto Cooler which is a
promotional tie-in to The Real
Ghostbusters Animated Series in the 80s
in previous episodes we saw a josta in a
Boku other discontinued drinks in the
center of the circle of chairs there is
a campfire of charred bowling pins next
to Alligator Loki is the mystery and
lore of monsters by CJs Thompson a rare
1930 book with accounts of major lore
Legends and human deformities both Loki
boasts of getting all six Infinity
Stones after defeating cap and Iron Man
and he has at least one doubter
that's alligator for grounding and
saying liar at the same time I love how
Gator Loki launches himself at Boswell
Loki and goes straight for his hand like
what he does later to president Loki or
like the crocodile that ate Captain Hook
sand classic Loki explains how he
survived Thanos I cast a projection of
myself so real even the Mad Titan
believed it
then hid as inanimate debris bookie
writer Michael Waldron said that he came
up with his backstory after wondering
what would have happened if Loki had
survived his death in Infinity War he
added quote it was that tragic thing
where he finally realizes I'm meant to
be alone it was just so sad there's a
real lesson there for our Loki and that
he's going to reject that notion that
this tiger can't change his stripes and
he refuses to be alone Loki wants to do
the right thing he wants to see if he
can have a real relationship in his life
and I have to give a quick aside here
because this whole theory of a piece of
debris floating behind Thanos says he
choked Loki Infinity war was absolutely
a theory that I discussed on the new
Rockstar Channel all the way back in
2018. so sure Michael Walton probably
came up with it on his own but I just
think it's awesome vitication for all of
us theorists back in 2018 that this
ridiculous Theory actually has some
plausibility to it okay so Loki meets
with another group of variants led by
President Loki from the 2016 comic
miniseries vote Loki in which Loki ran
for president of the United States on a
Bonkers campaign based around admitting
two line to the public we also see a
variant with a helmet with a bike
handlebar for horns one with a helmet of
silverware one with his Russian Style
hat with spiky things coming out of it
one holding a ball and chain and this
bearded one who we actually saw already
labeled variant l8914 back in episode
two one thing I want to point out about
this hatch is that it actually has some
Hindi writing on it because the whole
idea of this hatch is that it was going
to be taken from an Indian nuclear
submarine okay Sylvie kicks out the
front of the windshield on the school
bus that she woke up in in the
background we see the pruned ruins of a
suspension bridge that kind of looks
like a cross between Golden Gate Bridge
and Oakland Bay Bridge the Oakland Bay
Bridge better Bridge it's underrated
Golden Gate Bridge is fine Oakland just
looks so much cooler Elias sits down on
the bus and you can see that it sort of
rots it eroding it further so you
definitely don't want this thing
touching you later it does the same
thing to the crew of the USS Eldridge
Sylvie enchants a branch of eliaith and
gets a vision of what it is guarding a
rock ring suspended at the end of time a
citadel in a lit Tower Mobius saves her
in the nick of time by driving up in a
Datsun Bluebird wagon with a spring
mounted pizza slice on top courtesy of
Skinny's Pizza the plate number is
grnw1d a not to Marvel writer and Elias
creator Mark gruenwald in the comics
Mobius was actually modeled after
grunwald's appearance Mobius pulls up
next to a sign for wrightville theater
Wrightsville was mentioned in episode 4
as one of the places where an
apocalyptic event took place the theater
is actually screening Oswald in the
Martian a reference to the 1930 Disney
animated short Mars in which Oswald the
Lucky Rabbit meets The Martian King
Oswald the Lucky Rabbit also made a bit
of a cameo in Multiverse of Madness our
guys getting his MCU day inside the car
there is a hula girl on the dash in one
division the ice cream truck that Darcy
envisioned steel also has a hula girl
and one also significantly popped up
repeatedly in Agents of Shield Elias
follows them with pillars of smoke that
look very much like the smoke monster
from Lost Mobius makes a hard ride in
front of the Great Pyramid of Giza and a
pruned Sphinx with its nose still
attached there's also a structure in the
back on the right that kind of looks
like the Parthenon in Greece not sure
though the lokies betray each other for
power and our Loki shakes his head in
disgust at their pettiness
we prefer snakes to wolves I've eaten
both
[Music]
MCU Loki's Offspring in Norse mythology
alligator Loki bites off president
Loki's hand and all hell breaks loose as
everyone fights everyone our Loki
tiptoes through the chaos and we get
this cheery rock remix of the usually
dark and Moody Loki theme music
classic Loki escaped death at thanos's
Hand by using conjure magic while he
snuck away and he does the same thing
here to allow himself our Loki and kid
Loki and alligator Loki to escape
outside he says this
couple throats of every person who
trusts that simple what power glorious
power glorious purpose
we're broken every version of us forever
this was Loki's big fear but his Trust
of Sylvie convinces the others to help
him get past a liar the USS Eldridge
drops into the void and its crew still
on board this was a U.S Navy destroyer
that was decommissioned in Sulfur scrap
but became part of a conspiracy theory
stating that it was part of the
Philadelphia Experiment that rendered it
invisible rensslayer uses her temper to
summon Miss minutes who actually walks
with her down the hallway like they're
in the weirdest episode of an Aaron
Sorkin show ever the Loki group comes up
with a game plan at Dom's Cuts
Barbershop while roasting one of the
narvas over an open fire kid Loki asks
Mobius what happens if he gets back to
the TVA people know the truth so just
like that you're turning on the very
thing you diverted your life to
never too late to change classic Loki
takes that in and really considers it
after just saying that a Loki can never
change he got two back-to-back examples
that it is possible and this is the
moment he likely thinks back to later in
the episode when he sacrifices himself
this time for real one of the narvas
runs on top of a Chrysler TV8 a tank
designed by Chrysler in the 1950s that
never ended up in production as the
group stares at Elias we see the dark
Aster that was Ronan [__] from Guardians
of the Galaxy which got destroyed during
the Battle of xandar Loki asks Mobius
what will you do at the TVA
Burn It To The Ground this is a call
back to Loki's promise to do the same in
episode one I'm gonna burn this place to
the ground also the fact that he says
this while his face is over the shoulder
says that he could be whispering it both
into the ear of the person that he's
hugging into the person he's looking at
they both can take the compliment they
probably will because they're both you
know ego-filled now in the distance we
see the head of the Statue of the Living
Tribunal the three-headed Cosmic entity
tasked with overseeing and judging the
Multiverse whom we see in Thor love and
thunder and in the quick Clemson
Multiverse Madness and then right before
Elias obscures it we actually get a
glimpse of the Hydra hella carrier a
Helicarrier controlled by Hydra they
might be connected to the Multiverse
Madness version of the hydro reality
where Hydra took over remember the Hydra
blimp there's also piles of Boons which
might belong to the leviathans those
were the creatures that the Qatari used
during the Battle of New York Loki waves
his flaming sword trying to distract
eliaith the way Alan Grant waved the
flare around in Jurassic Park to
distract the T-Rex but it doesn't work
because as classic Loki said earlier the
blades are worthless in the face of a
low-key sorcery the stunt a magical
potential so classic Loki steps in and
does his thing and is written all over
his face that this is his true glorious
purpose
Natalie Holtz music is incredible she
used a 32 Voice Choir for the vocals and
it also Staples Wagner's Norse inspired
Ride of the Valkyries you know the music
that played the beginning of Apocalypse
Now classic Loki casts an illusion of
Asgard and even after all of these years
he remembers every little detail of it
which makes me wonder if in those years
of lonely self-exile he would cast these
Illusions just to get a glimpse of Home
Loki and Sylvie Gaze on and wonder and
next to them is a Burger Chef sign that
was a real life Burger chain that was
eventually bought out by Hardee's the
illusion Fades and classic Loki
apparently gets consumed although I have
hopes we will see him again in season
two somehow Richard E Grant is just so
great in this role even before he was
cast he was the one they wanted for it
their first and only choice and his face
was even used in the concept art Sylvia
and Loki successfully enchant Elia they
are bathed in this green light as if
they are looking upon Oz's Emerald City
and hand in hand they walk towards the
Citadel of he who remains okay later
today you're gonna see our breakdown of
season 2 episode 1 after that episode
comes out but we're still gonna finish
out this rewatch series our re-breakdown
of episode 6 for all time always the
final episode of season one is going to
be coming out next week and we're going
to look again closely at every little
thing he remains says because I think
it's gonna be really important to
understand season two please subscribe
to all three channels the new rockstars
Network you can follow me at eavos
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time bye
thank you
[Music]